[Aplausos]
[Música]
entre el océano pacífico y el mar caribe
podemos decir que colombia es algo así
como la puerta de entrada de sudamérica
y sabéis que todo esto es colombia las
largas y animadas playas de santa marta
el desierto de la guajira o la
inaccesible letizia capital de la
frondosa amazonia colombiana las islas
de san andrés y providencia puro caribe
colombiano el eje cafetero de quindío
caldas y risaralda o como no las
vibrantes ciudades de medellín cali
barranquilla y todo ello claro sin poder
olvidarnos de la histórica y orgullosa
cartagena o de la frenética bogotá la
gran capital del país que amigos con su
candelaria su cerro de monserrate o los
increíbles museos del oro y de botero te
dejarán literalmente con la boca abierta
de verdad no podemos extrañarnos de que
cada vez más guías turísticas sitúen a
colombia como un destino 100%
obligatorio porque amigos y os lo digo
por experiencia propia colombia
un país diverso y con ritmo mucho ritmo
sus calles sus comercios su gastronomía
esa bandeja paisa de verdad amigos de
visual político os doy mi palabra estoy
deseando volver a colombia
pero como os podéis imaginar este vídeo
no va de turismo para nada
en mayo de 2018 se celebrarán elecciones
presidenciales y el 7 de agosto este
país estrenará nuevo presidente porque
el actual juan manuel santos ha cumplido
ya el límite de dos mandatos pues
precisamente como la etapa de santos ha
entrado en su recta final queremos con
este vídeo echar un vistazo a la
colombia que deja a su sucesor con sus
luces y sus sombras
[Música]
la colombia de hoy
apostador y gran jugador de poker juan
manuel santos- forma parte de una de las
familias tradicionalmente más
influyentes de colombia
su propio tío abuelo eduardo santos ya
fue presidente del país allá por finales
de la década de los treinta y su familia
fue durante décadas propietaria del
diario 'el tiempo' el periódico más
importante de colombia casi nada
de hecho el propio juan manuel santos-
fue durante mucho tiempo subdirector y
columnista de este periódico
'vamos que influencia dinero y poder a
esta familia nunca le ha faltado
[Música]
pues bien tras dos legislaturas el
pasado 7 de agosto de 2017 arrancó el
último año de juan manuel santos como
presidente y la verdad sea dicha lo hace
con unos niveles de popularidad que
están por los suelos fijaos a pesar de
haber incluso ganado el premio nobel de
la paz por el acuerdo con las farc según
los últimos estudios publicados entre el
65 y el 75 por ciento de los colombianos
desaprueba su gestión así que la
pregunta es cómo diantres todo un nobel
de la paz puede tener semejante grado de
desaprobación bueno puede que algo tenga
que ver la controversia sobre su
compromiso claro de que el pueblo
colombiano tendría siempre la última
palabra en el acuerdo de paz con las
farc algo que como sabéis no fue del
todo así bueno digamos que santos se
olvidó de su palabra
pero sobre todo amigos dejando de lado
este punto si por algo es tan suspendido
por los colombianos es por la marcha de
la economía
así es durante la última década este
puma del pacífico' llamado colombia ha
tenido un crecimiento bastante potente y
llegó a convertirse sin duda en uno de
los países de moda de toda latinoamérica
sin embargo las cosas últimamente son un
poco distintas por no decir bastante
atentos a este gráfico
hoy amigos colombia se enfrenta a una
situación de desaceleración casi de
estancamiento fijaos el último dato de
crecimiento conocido refleja un
crecimiento interanual tan solo
ligeramente por encima del 1% y la
previsión para el conjunto de 2017 no es
mucho mejor de acuerdo con cálculos de
bmw research la economía colombiana
crecería un 1 5 por ciento en 2017 como
veis este no es precisamente un buen
dato sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta que
la mayor parte de los países más ricos
están creciendo más
eeuu canadá españa alemania reino unido
todos ellos crecerán más que colombia en
2017 y claro se supone que cuando eres
más pobre tienes que crecer más por eso
de la convergencia nos parece así que
llegados a este punto la pregunta es qué
está pasando con colombia muchos culpan
de esta situación a la caída de los
precios del petróleo de las materias
primas y en cierto modo tienen algo de
razón pero con matices
es verdad que en su momento de mayor
apogeo en 2013 el petróleo llegó a
representar más del 50 por ciento de
todas las exportaciones más del 30 por
ciento de toda la inversión extranjera
directa y más del 20 por ciento de los
ingresos públicos pero también es verdad
que durante años gracias al elevado
precio del petróleo el gobierno de
colombia ha disfrutado de más recursos
que nunca antes recursos que podría
haber utilizado amigos para impulsar una
economía productiva y competitiva más
allá de las materias primas y esto es
algo que no parece que el gobierno de
juan manuel santos haya sido capaz de
hacer tal vez por haber estado centrado
casi en exclusiva en el acuerdo con las
farc en fin veamos cuáles siguen siendo
a día de hoy los principales puntos
débiles de la economía colombiana
[Música]
el desastre de las infraestructuras
durante años colombia ha sido como
decirlo casi como un estado fallido en
muchas zonas de su territorio zonas que
eran controladas por auténticos señores
de la guerra guerrillas paramilitares
narcos así que imaginad lo difícil que
puede llegar a ser gestionar un país así
y lo difícil que resulta construir
infraestructuras ahora bien no os
penséis que es sólo esto para nada
y la verdad es que las infraestructuras
nunca han sido una gran prioridad para
los diferentes gobiernos colombianos y
el resultado de todo ello ha sido
terrible
hoy las infraestructuras de colombia son
francamente malas y con carencias de
todo tipo
el gobierno tiene que entender que
también se requiere así como se le
apunta al desarrollo en las sociedades
portuarias se le tiene que apuntar
también a la flota de cabotaje el
pacífico
el resultado atentos a los datos porque
los van a sorprender
mover un contenedor de mercancías por el
interior del país es el doble de caro
que hacerlo en méxico o bolivia y casi
cuatro veces más caro que en argentina
chile o perú de hecho la situación es
tan desastrosa que el transporte de
mercancías entre el puerto colombiano de
buenaventura y bogotá es casi tres veces
más caro que llevar la misma carga de
rotterdam a frankfurt bueno es más es
que según algunos cálculos enviar un
contenedor desde el puerto de cartagena
a bogotá cuesta el triple que enviarlo
desde la propia cartagena a shanghai
ya os podéis hacer una idea de todas las
implicaciones que esto tiene para los
costes de suministro los precios y la
competitividad de las empresas
colombianas en el último reporte de
todos los países que seguimos según los
costos de exportar un contenedor
colombia es el tercero más costoso del
mundo luego de venezuela y rusia por
esto el propio juan manuel santos- fijó
en 2010 como su prioridad número uno
cambiar esta realidad y es verdad su
gobierno acaba de lanzar el mayor plan
de infraestructuras de la historia de
colombia
[Música]
y un país en marcha
estamos construyendo el programa de
infraestructura más grande de nuestra
historia
un plan con cofinanciación privada y
bajo un sistema de concesiones bastante
atractivo si el plan parece bien
diseñado pero amigos tras siete años
llega con cierto retraso y muchos
problemas es decir a decir verdad en sus
casi dos legislaturas los logros de
santos no han sido todo lo bueno que
prometió que iban a ser
[Música]
burocracia e impuestos
tanto el foro económico mundial como el
banco mundial afirman ojo que colombia
es uno de los países de todo el mundo
con impuestos más altos a las empresas
lo que evidentemente no es algo que
ayude a que éstas crezcan y se
desarrollen mira según el informe
pagando impuestos que cada año publica
price waterhouse coopers house water
watch cooper la suma de todas las cargas
fiscales a las que se enfrenta una
empresa colombiana suponen el 69,8 por
ciento de todo su beneficio antes de
todos los impuestos porque recordad que
las empresas pagan más impuestos además
del impuesto sobre beneficios casi el 70
por ciento mucho más que en países como
alemania españa eeuu una locura y
respecto a la burocracia pues tres
cuartas partes de lo mismo un día en un
siguiente vídeo tendríamos que analizar
la afición latinoamericana por la
burocracia porque de verdad tiene miga
el caso es que en colombia de media se
emiten al día alrededor de 15 normas y
tres decretos y no sólo eso según un
estudio realizado por la universidad de
la sabana más del 30 por ciento de todas
las leyes aprobadas son inútiles y sólo
generan costes a la sociedad y que ha
hecho juan manuel santos sobre todas
estas cuestiones pues prácticamente nada
incluso ha empeorado el escenario de
salida
[Música]
la violencia persistente
es verdad que muchos ámbitos
relacionados con la seguridad están
mejorando en colombia' y buen reflejo de
ello es lo que está ocurriendo por
ejemplo en el sector turístico mira en
2016 algo más de 5 millones de turistas
visitaron este país más del doble que en
2010 y casi 10 veces más que en el año
2000 no está mal verdad sin embargo a
pesar de ello en muchas zonas del país
la situación no está mejorando según
naciones unidas y también el centro de
recursos para el análisis del conflicto
la violencia persiste en las zonas del
país más afectadas sin que el acuerdo
con las farc haya mejorado
sustancialmente la situación
de hecho amigos por ejemplo la
producción de coca y también de cocaína
se encuentra hoy en su máximo histórico
prestas atención a este gráfico
pero puede que os estáis preguntando
cómo es posible que los niveles de
violencia y de producción de sustancias
ilícitas no se hayan reducido tras el
acuerdo del gobierno con las farc bueno
primero porque a pesar de toda la
campaña del gobierno la violencia de las
farc era enorme es verdad pero suponía
menos del 10 por ciento de toda la
violencia nacional y además de donde las
farc se ha marchado su presencia ha sido
suplida no por las instituciones sino en
muchos casos por otros grupos mafiosos o
de narcos ojo en muchos casos de mutuo
acuerdo con antiguos mandos de las farc
al fin y al cabo amigos el negocio sigue
siendo muy lucrativo lo dijimos aquí en
visual político el acuerdo con las farc
dejaba muchas cosas en el aire y por
todo esto el llamado dividendo de la paz
no está siendo tan grande como prometió
el gobierno pero seamos justos no todo
ha sido malo o regular en el gobierno de
santos
[Música]
y la mejor cara de la administración
santos hay que reconocer que el gobierno
de santos también ha tenido algunos
logros juan manuel santo se incorporó a
colombia a la alianza del pacífico cuyo
éxito ya nos contó aquí alberto en un
pasado vídeo y desde luego la política
exterior ha sido sin duda el campo donde
más fuerte ha sido este gobierno hoy
colombia está mucho más abierta al
exterior que la etapa anterior a santos
hablamos del comercio de visados de
relaciones etcétera etcétera y junto a
ello la pobreza se ha reducido bastante
y el país ha captado mucha inversión
extranjera
[Música]
son logros destacados pero aún con todo
mi impresión es que la llegada de un
nuevo gobierno puede ser una buena
noticia para colombia mirad cuando juan
manuel santos llegó a la casa de nariño
el país parecía encontrarse listo para
abordar un proceso de transformación
completo y los recursos petroleros
estaban ahí para pagar la factura sin
embargo esto no se ha conseguido muy al
contrario santos dejar a una colombia
con una situación económica débil y
muchos más proyectos de futuro que de
presente en fin turno para ti cómo
valoras a santos si tuvieras que poner
nota a su gestión como la calificaría
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta no te olvides
de darle laical vídeo si te ha resultado
interesante y de suscribirte abisal
polític si aún no lo has hecho por
cierto esperar un momento chile también
está a las puertas de un cambio de
gobierno así que si quieres conocer cómo
le ha ido bajo la presidencia de
michelle bachelet no te pierdas este
vídeo un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]